[Music]
in a world of high fantasy low comedy
and special effects wankery a big Studio
adaptation of a beloved nerd franchise
will turn out not awful kind of fun
actually funny okay lock the doors
nobody leaves this room until we figure
out how this happened Dungeons and
Dragons hat I mean honor among Thieves
you memory hole Dungeons and Dragons
2000 and if you remember the cartoon
your kids are waiting for you to pick
them up from school now strap in for a
film that takes a wild new approach what
if a Marvel movie were as Charming as it
thinks it is with cool magic
good jokes
approved your pardon and action with
some thought put into it
so what if they drop a magic Sky Beam at
the end it's been a while since we had a
good Sky beam I missed you old friend
when you need a bar to not suck there's
only one Hollywood Chris you should call
he's got the charm the sex appeal the
magic voice
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
and the track record of abandoning
mixed-race daughters he told me to trust
you when you left me Pine's got the
range baby show me just one thing that
Chris Pratt is better at
except making money Pines again will
team up with Michelle Rodriguez as wait
wait wait get this a tough lady
she's a barbarian with a heart of gold
and a tiny man fetish they'll join Simon
a whiz with no rizz I caught to do
he said it made you feel sad
yeah Doric the Druid the only one
without any character development
because she's too busy getting done
[Music]
and the Paladin zank who is clearly an
NPC that the DM dropped in to get those
idiots unstuck and back on the main
quest line they're much better at
advising and strategy pretty much
everything together they'll face off
against Hugh Grant who's now just a good
bloke who plays villains instead of back
in the 90s when it was the opposite and
the red Wizard sophina who's just here
to glower until the big bad Rose in for
the sequel
nearly complete Lisa Jeremy Irons played
this guy in the sequel he deserves
another crack at this
tired of films where the heroes are even
momentarily in actual Peril with a scrap
in for an adventure they're massively
over leveled for
[Music]
featuring a team with so much plot armor
their fierce's foe spawns in with
diabetes
where even the one weapon in the entire
fantasy universe that can actually hurt
someone it's a rut was displayed there's
nothing I can do does it
and the only way they can be defeated is
by constantly forgetting magic exists in
their extremely magical world just talk
the time stuff
you'd have thought that you'd have
learned that the last time she trapped
you
see this is why you always need to bring
a palette in but they just let theirs
walk away
so if you want to take the game that's
quietly been influencing all pop culture
in the background for decades and do it
justice on the big screen Why not pick
the team that already turned a nerdy
game night into a hilarious action
comedy guys make sure you get a piece of
this cheese wait don't tell me you
haven't seen game night what oh you have
to see it in fact you should pause this
video and go watch it right now there's
no pausing don't worry we'll wait one
two three
oh
what did you finish it yet then Jesse
plemons the dog is so good right uh
where was I oh yeah Dungeons and Dragons
it's good I bet Paramount and stove oh
uh well I bet E1 and Hasbro are
celebrating okay someone needs to
explain to me how success Works in this
industry
369 bar Chris Pine death Vice news new
if he's lawful good why did he steal the
movie The Justice Society Anna Moore Oh
the Hugh Grant a thief wizards of
shaverly place every franchise needs a
Thanos Gone Girl Mini Cooper AI art and
bad Dragon Google it while you're at
work Party of Five
hi are you a movie wife does your
husband insist on Staring at you smiling
under white sheets run for your life
fast X comes out this weekend so we're
breaking down the stats on every race
fight jump man hug Corona family tank
top and More in an all-new episode of by
the Numbers huffa take a NOS then click
the Box on the right to watch now just
kidding don't actually Huff Nars
bad baby no squeezes
my favorite honest trailer is a tie
between Deadpool and Pacific Rim now
stop asking